for Marseille in the South to Leon
konobla and the capital Paris public
property cars and businesses looted
torged and destroyed
the Nationwide anger on the streets
follows the killing of 17-year-old Niall
during a police traffic stop on Tuesday
the French President is calling for calm
and says the Situation's been hijacked
to spread Anarchy
this is an unacceptable exploitation of
the death of a teenager which we deplore
this time should all be about
contemplation and respect I strongly
condemn those who are using this
situation to try and create disorder and
Target our institutions
France's football team have also
appealed for an end to the unrest
Captain kylian mbappe tweeting a
statement from the players saying they
all understand the anger the dialogue
needs to be the focus not violence
following hundreds of arrests already
this week
hundreds more were detained overnight
the mayor of Marseille said looting and
violence is unacceptable and urged the
government in Paris to send police
reinforcements
Nile's funeral has taken place here in
Monte at the end of a very difficult few
days for the family and particularly for
the teenager's mother she has lost her
only son Natasha Butler Al Jazeera
montaire